تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام بعد اربع سنوات
على الثوره السوريه لماذا بدا النظام
السوري يستعين بشكل مفضوح
بمليشيات طائفيه حسره
الم يصدع رؤوسنا على مدى عقود بانه نظام
قومي عروبي
فلماذا يستعين بشيعه ايران وباكستان
وافغانستان والعراق ولبنان واليمن تحديدا
هل هذه هي منطلقات حزب البعث العروبي
الاشتراكي القومي قال واحده عربيه قال
الم يكشر بشار الاسد عن انيابه الطائفيه
بشكل صارخ الم يكن ذلك النظام طائفيا
اقلويا منذ وصوله الى السلطه قبل عقود
المبع مدينه دمشق القديمه لايران بالوثائق
الا يصح جنوده وضباطه يا علي يا زينب يا
حسين وهم يرمون البراميل المتفجره ويطلقون
صواريخ اسكد على المناطق السنيه
الم يحرض الدروز ويحرضهم الان على جيرانهم
في درعا الم يحرض العلويين على السنه الم
يدق الاسفين الطائفيه بين مكونات الشعب
السوري كي يعيش على تناقضاته وتناحره على
المبدا الاستعماري الشهير فرق تسد
الا يتشدق بحمايه الاقليات وهو الذي قتل
كل رموز الاقليات في سوريا ولبنان اليس
المسؤولون السنه في نظام الاسد مجرد
طراطير حتى في الجيش والامن
لكن في المقابل الم يلجا معارضون نظام الى
الشعارات الطائفيه والمذهبيه منذ بدايه
الثوره اليس من حقه ان يستحينا بمليشيات
شيعيه قريبه من طائفته اذا كان الطرف
الاخر يخوض الحرب ضد النظام على اساس
مذهبي مفضوح الا تعلن بعض فصائل المعارضه
بانها تقاتل
النصيريين علنا اليس من حق النظام ان
يتمترس طائفيا اذا الم تحذر مستشاره
الرئيس من الخطر الطائفي منذ بدايه الثوره
الا يشكل السنه الجزء الاكبر من الجيش
السوري الذي يسميه البعض زورا وبهتانا جيش
النظام الا يبقى نظاما علمانيا قوميا اما
زال يتغنى بدمشقى قلب العروبه النابض
اسئله نطرحه على الهواء مباشره على
المستشار خالد شبيب رئيس المنظمه الدوليه
لحقوق الانسان وعلى الكاتب والباحث السوري
السيد عبد المسيح الشامي نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج الاتجاه
والمعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على موضوع هذه
الحلقه هل تعتقد ان النظام السوريه لعب
على وتر الطائفيه منذ بدايه الثوره سته
96.2 نعم 3.8 لا لو بدات معك بهذه النتيجه
المستشار خالد شبيب يعني ما الذي يعني هذه
الشريحه بغض النظر تمثل او لا تمثل يعني
هي باخر النهار تمثل الذين صوتوا هل يعقل
ان هذه الشريحه تعتقد ان هذا النظام
يدق خوازيق طائفيه منذ بدايه الثوره فقط
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هذه النتيجه دكتور لو كانت نتيجه ضد بهذا
الشكل كان انسحبت فورا
دكتور فيصل قبل البدء انطلاقا من نتيجه
التصويت سارد لك حقائق ومعلومات وليس
كلاما جزافا ارجو ان تسمح لي اولا رئيس
الجمهوريه
رجل ينتخبه الشعب يدور يدير سياسه الدوله
الداخليه وخارجيا لمصلحه الشعب وبرضاه
ولمصلحته ومقابل اجر يعني ماجور وكيل
بالعموله
عندما يقترف هذا الرئيس جرائم بحق الشعب
وضد مصلحه الشعب من حق الشعب ان يعزله
ويحاكمه اريد التاكيد على مساله هامه جدا
في سوريا الشعب في سوريا بقوائفه التي
نعتز بها لا يمكن ان يتعايش الا ضمن اطار
واحد وفق معيارين المعيار الاول المعايير
الانسانيه حقوق الانسان الثاني الاحترام
المتبادل ثانيا الشعب السوري وطني وليس
طائفي بدليل قادته الذين مشى خلفهم سلطان
باشا الاطرش قائد الثوره السوريه درزي
صالح العلي النصيري فارس الخوري من الاخوه
المسيحيين وكان يعاونه من المقربين اليه
الشيخ محمد المبارك احد مؤسسين الاخوان
المسلمين الذي بنى بنى ميناء اللاذقيه في
هذا السياق يقول الدكتور ياسر سعد الدين
مفكر اسلامي الدليل على انه شعبنا وطني
وغير طائفي فيصل قاسم وشعبيته وعدد
المتابعين له ولو انه يرشح الان لرئاسه
الجمهوريه لانتخبه الشعب السوري حتى لو
رشح امامه البزم او احمد كفتارو او حسون
او الى اخره الاسلاميون المسلمين اذا
ليسوا طائفين الشعب السوري ليس طائفه من
اين نبدا بالحديث عن طائفيه النظام هل
تريد ان ابدا من جد العاشر لبشار الاسد
ابن العلقمي الذي سلم بغداد
ام عن جد المباشر سلمان الاسد الذي طالب
بوثيقه رسميه مساعده الفرنسيين بدوله
علويه طائفيه منطلق من منطلقا من كلمته
نحن لست مسلمين ولا ننسجم مع الدين
الاسلامي الوثيقه موجوده في فرنسا في
فرنسا وقال لها ممثل فرنسا في الامم
المتحده بدايه عام 63 بدا حافظ اسد
بالتسلق على السلطه وبدا يخطط الى النظام
الطائفي الممنهج من بعد الانقلاب العسكري
قام بعده اعدامات بتصفيه كبار الضباط اعدم
سليم حاطوم
من كبار الدروس ونسب اليه جرم الخيانه
العظمى واعدم عبد الكريم الجندي من الاخوه
الاسماعيليين وعدم مئات الضباط الكبار
وسرح الالاف حتى الجارديان ذكرت في احد
اعدادها ان 2400 ضابط من رتبه عميد فما
فوق سرحهم حافظ الاسد واستعان بدلهم بضباط
من الطائفه النصيريه عمل لهم دوره اربع
شهور بدل اربع سنوات ماذا فعل بلبنان كما
قلت انت في بدايه الحلقه دخل الجيش على
لسوريا على لبنان لايقاف الحرب الطائفيه
وقتل زعماء لبنان قتل الرئيس بشير جمايل
من الطائفه المسيحيه وقتل برج ميل ورئيس
تحرير جريده الحياه التويني جبران توني
وقسم المسيحيين 50 قسم ثم قتل من الدروز
زعيمهم كمال جمبلاط وقتل من رموز السنه
رفيق الحريري صبحي صالح شعبان المفتي وسحق
الفلسطينيين في تل الزعتر وقسمهم ايضا
وحاصره ياسر
مجازر الطائفه في حماه الكل يذكر الحرب
الطائفيه ب 82 قتل 45
45 الف في حماه وقام بمذابح ايضا ضد
المسلمين السنه في تدمر وفي سيدنا
الطائفه المسيحيه عباره عن عن عباره عن
فقط جعلهم كومبارس لا محل لهم من الاعراب
فقط المسيحيين عند عند الجلي صحون قوم يا
انطون وعند اغتسام اقتسام الغنائم انطون
نائم في عام 77 انا اعرف هذا في فسقيه
اقدم العقيد الطائفي محسن سلوم على قتل
زعيم اسقالبيه المسيحي حكمه واخذ ارضه
غصبا وقطع اذن في شخص رئيس البلديه بطش
بارض املاك الدوله قالوا لك يا اخي ما
بصير هاي املاك دوله راح بطش فيها وقطع
اذنه هذا من بيت من بيت ايوب ايضا جعل قرى
المسيحيين سكنات عسكريه الان تنطلق من
الصواريخ والدبابات
هذا صحيح نحن كنا بالامس كنا هناك في
سوريا ونعرف ذلك دكتور محرده جعلها سكنه
عسكريه انا اتحداك انت سالك 15 سنه ما
دخلت
المسيحيين
نحن نحترم المسيحيون المسيحيين يا استاذي
الفاضل ناس فضلاء ساهموا في في النهضه
العربيه وفي سوريا باختصار شديد لكن الان
هو يريد ان ينحرف بالمسيحيه وراء النظام
ليس لمصلحتك وليس لمصلحه اقرب اقرباء او
في في المسيحيين في سوريا قالوا عبد
المسيح لا يمثلنا نحن مع الشعب السوري
وليس مع النظام نظام بشار الاسد باختصار
باختصار باختصار حامل اقليات سلح احياء
النصيريه في سوريا وسلح المدن النصيريه في
كل المحافظات حامل اقليات انشا جي طائفيا
كانت السيارات تجوب القرى النصيريه والمدن
النصيريه وتذيع بمكبرات الصوت اللي بده
يتفضل انت مقبول بالمخابرات وبالجيش اتفضل
على الدوره مباشره لذلك جعل الجيش 95% من
الجيش من الطائفه النصيريه والمخابرات
والمخابرات كذلك
لاحظ الفرقه الرابعه والحرس الجمهوري
والقوات الخاصه 99 والباقي لباقي الطوائف
بعام 2003 دكتور كان كنا نتغدى فوق قاسيون
انا كنت عم اتغدى بوكاسيون وكان معنا ضابط
اسمه عمار حاتفالي بعميد في الحرس
الجمهوري تعرف شو قال نحن
الشام دمشق وتحتنا دوما قال بتعرفوا
حي الشام اهل ومالي ونسوان حلال شايفين
اسمع اسمع
هذا هذا النظام الطائفي هاي حقيقه النظام
الطائفي
الاقتصاد ايضا جعله بيد ثلاث عائلات الي
الاسد وائل مخلوفه
ومنع الاستيراد فقط
قال له يا رجل
ميت بعثه من جماعتكم واثنين واحد مسيحي
وواحد سنه شو قال له قال له انت طائفي لو
محافظ اسد حاولتك على محكمه الميدان يعني
لاحقا خلينا السلك الدبلوماسي كمان
هذه اخر مره بياخذ
طائفيه النظام بسوريا بده يتذكر انه من
اربع سنين حتى الان الناس تذبح على هويه
الطائفيه النساء تغتصب على هويه الطائفيه
انت فهمت خليك موضوعي خليك موضوعي سيد
خالد
بدون مقاطعه تفضل يلا الاف الفتاوى حتى
الان والكل شاهد هذا الامر على الاف
الشاشات وكل يوم 24 ساعه متواصله فتى
والقرضاوي وفتاوى العرعور وفتاوى
الى الوقت عبد المسيح اجلس اجلس لا لا لا
اجلس اجلس هذا شخص عبد المسيح عبد المسيح
عبد المسيح ارجع عبد المسيح
عبد المسيح عبد المسيح ارجوك ترجع عبد
المسيح
ضعيف هو ما عنده شيء طيب نحاول خليه يرجع
لو تكرمت طيب نعود الى كيف ترد على الرجل
خليه اول شيء اعطيه دوره ارجوك رجاء
اخذت ما يكفي من الوقت لتقول ما تشاء
عقيده ارجوك رجاء رجاء يا ريت يرجع الاخ
عبد المسيح يقول لك الرجل لو احصيت عدد
الفتاوى
الطائفيه من الطرف الاخر لفقت كل ما تكلمت
عنه عن عن النظام وطائفه النظام هذا
الكلام غير صحيح انا قلت لك دكتور انا
اعطيك حقائق واعطيك معلومات ما بحكي قلقله
يعني بس والله نحن جايين بنتنقل بنقره نحن
عنا نسوان تفضحت يا رجل واغتصبت ونحن عنا
عنا ربع مليون
قتل وعنا نص مليون معتقل وعنا اربع ملايين
مهجر وعنا 12 مليون مشرد داخل سوريا يا
رجل جايين نحن عم بحكي لك انا بقائع
ومعلومات مين نحن يعني مين نحن مين نحن
الشعب السوري المضطهد المذبوح المقتول
الذي يعاني من الطائفيه من اكثر من اربعين
سنه لما قامت الثوره السوريه دكتور فيصل
قامت الثوره سلميه بشار الاسد بذاته ماذا
قال قال سته اشهر كانت سلميه طيب سته اشهر
ماذا فعلت ليش ما جيت انت قلت
موضوع الثوره السوريه موضوعي انت تقول انه
بعد اربع سنوات انكشف النظام الطائفي
تماما اعطيني امثله ولا تريد لا تحكي لي
عن ثوره السوريه تفضل انا راح انت حكيت
تاريخ الان تمام كيف تمثل هذا النظام او
كيف مارس طائفيته او السلاح الطائفي على
مدى الاربع سنوات الماضيه راح احكي لك بس
يعني في مقدمه صغيره الشعب السوري
خلال ست اشهر لم يدافع عن نفسه وكان شباب
يواجهون الرصاص بصدورهم
انا بحكي النظام الطائفي بدا بالمذابح
الطائفيه الجماعيه على طول وعرض الساحه
السوريه من درعا مهدي الثوره الى دوما الى
الغوطه الى الحوله الى تريمسه الى الخضراء
حماه الرقه دير الزور المناطق السنيه
جميعا وكان ضباط السنه وعناصر السنه في
مقدمه الجيش وكان عناصر السنه في مقدمه
الجيش وكانوا يقتلون من الخلف برصاص
بالرصاص الحاقد الطائفه الطائفي تفضل سيد
سيد خالد سيد خالد انت جاوبت الان الدور
لعبد المسيح ولن اسمح باي مقاطعه من
الطرفين تفضل اخ المسيح وخذ الوقت انت عم
تعطي
يا اخي الله اكبر منك سيد خالد سيد خالد
سيد خالد مو طبيعتي سيد خالد تفضل اسمع
سيد خالد سيد خالد سيد خالد سيد خالد سيد
خالد
استغفر الله العظيم يا رجل استغفر الله
طيب يا اخي صار لك ساعه بتحكي خليه يتكلم
طيب يعني انت عطيت انطباعه كويس الان هو
الرجل خليه يكمل الزلمه اخي هو الرجل ما
عنده شيء يا اخي ما عنده شيء خلينا نسمعه
طيب انا خلينا نسمعه انا بدير الحلقه رجاء
بدك ما احكي خالص حاضر
حاضر
طيب اتفضل يا ريت اخ عبد المسيح ارجوك
ارجوك ارجوك لك الوقت اتفضل اتفضل اتفضل
يا اخي خليه يكمل خليه يكمل يا اخي خليه
كمل خليه كمل تفضل
طيب خلينا نتكلم ارجع ارجع للنقاط رد
عليها اذا دكتور الحقد الطائفي متجذر
بالنظام ما يحصل اليوم هو هو عباره عن
تراكمات طائفيه عملت خلال عقود وجهد والا
كيف انت بتفسر مثل ما ذكرت انت بالمقدمه
هذا الترتيب الرهيب مع الحوثيين والافغان
والباكستاني والايرانيين واستقدام كل هذه
الجماعات الضخمه منهم لولا ان يكون هناك
اعداد مرتب خلال عقود من الزمن هناك مقاله
للدكتور
عميد المراقبين العرب الذين دخلوا سوريا
بمهمه رسميه له مقال يتحدث بتفصيل عن
بتفصيله احصاءات عن الفصائل الطائفيه التي
تقاتل في سوريا وعدد افرادها وكل مهمه لكل
واحد منها الوافده لبنان وايران واليمن
وباكستان كما ذكرت بس خلينا خلينا نجلي
هذه النقطه يعني تريد ان تقول انه طائفيه
النظام انفضحت تماما عندما بدا يستعين
بمليشيات طائفيه تحديدا من اليمن ومن
لبنان ومن العراق هذا هو تماما
معاهده الدفاع العربي المشترك لاحظ انت مو
نحن عرب يا اخي طيب ليش استلخت سوريا عن
محيطها العربي انت عمل بدال معاهده الدفاع
المشترك عمل معاهده الدفاع المشترك موثقه
موجوده مع ايران واستحاض عنها حافظ الاسد
وبشار الاسد بايش بمعاد الدفاع المشترك مع
ايران وبقي ياخذ الاموال من الدول العربيه
والدول الخليج كانت تدفع تقطع عن عن
اولاده وعن نساء او اطفاله وتعطي لحافظ
اسد على اساس شو ايش على اساس المقاومه
ومواجهه للدفاع للصهاينه وموازنه
استراتيجيه وكذا والى اخره بينما بينما
بينما كان هو عامل الدفاع مشترك مع ايران
ماذا يعني دكتور الفاضل
ماذا يعني انه تجنيس عدد كبير من
الايرانيين كما حكيت انت الان ويشترون
دمشق الان يشتروا دمشق مسموح لهم انه
يشتروا عقارات في دمشق وممنوع على رعايه
العرب ان يشتروا عقارات مو بدمشق بسوريا
كلياتها طيب اليس هناك من المبالغه ان
يقولوا مثلا انه دمشق القديمه دمشق
القديمه من داريا السيده سكينه الى السيده
زينب الى المطار يعني نصف دمشق بيعه
للايرانيين بخمسه مليارات دولار هل هذا
صحيح يا دكتور مبيعات هذه بيعه سوريا
كلياتها ليش من المتحكم الان في سوريا
متحكم بشار الاسد متحكمه ايران في سوريا
انا سؤال اسالك ماذا يعني بناء الحسينيات
والمزارات في سوريا تهديم الاف المساجد
وحرقه وتمزيق المصاحف ويقولون بشار الاسد
ربك من يقول لها قول بشار الاسد ربك يقتله
واللي ما يقول بشار الاسد ربك كمان يقتله
حامل اقلياتها دكتور قتل من طائفه واحده
ربع مليون واعتقل
نصف مليون وهجر منهم اربع ملايين وشرد
منهم 12 مليون
سنه نحن الان مذبوحين مخلوقين يا رجل
اعراضنا استبيحت يا اخي لاحظ انت هناك
مقالات عديده في هذه الصدد تحدثت عن طائفه
النظام والتهان النظام بحضن ايران دكتور
محمد المصري
وصالح القلاب والدكتور النفيسي كل هؤلاء
يتحدثون نخلص بالقول هذا الكلام الى
الحقيقه التي يجب ان تعلمها الطائفه
النصيريه بشار الاسد ينتعلكم بشار ينتعل
الطائفه النسوريه شبابها ونسائها يضحي بهم
والى الان من اجل الكرسي من اجل الكرسي
ومن اجل الارتهاني
والدليل على انه لا يبادل الضباط
النصيريين
بالمحتجزين يبادل من يبادل عن الضباط
الايرانيين ليس عن انت مره حكيت وتوسطت
عند الشباب في محتجزه او حتى عند النظام
وطلعت بعض الاخ من السويداء تصور انت ولك
انت مو رئيس الكل بتمن على الدكتور فيصل
ويروح يعطي للايرانيين فقط اما النسيريين
يبقون ويقتلون ما في مشكله لاحظ بشار
الاسد بشار الاسد سيبيد هذه الطائفه
بالكامل لان الثوار لن يتوقفوا حتى اسقاط
بشار الاسد وسيحاكمونه باعتبار اعتراف
ضباط النصيريه قتل منهم 100 الف بشار
الاسد جعل الطائفه مجرمه محتقره لدى
العالم وفي عيون اقرب المقربين جعله
مشبيحه قتله اين كانت الطائفه قبل ان ياتي
حافظ الاسد وبشار الاسد
كانت كبيره في عيون الناس بشار الاسد
جعلهم الان شبيحه وقتل ومجرمين بشار الاسد
بعد ان تنتهي الطائفه من خدمه المشروع
الايراني تنتهي من القتل طبعا عندما
يسحقها بالكامل سيتركها بالشهر الاسد
ويذهب بشار الاسد الى عند اسياده ويترك
هذه الطائفه اشياء ممزقه تواجه مصيرها
ويهرب الى عندي اسياده اسياد بشار الاسد
يا دكتور في ايران يسكنون يسكون الروح
الطائفيه ويهددون باقتحام ال العراق
ولبنان وسوريا والاردن
واليمن ويقولون انت سمعت نائب الرئيس يا
رجل نائب الرئيس الايراني يقول والعرب سوف
نحسرهم الى مكه والمدينه لا والبعض قال
اخر منهم ايضا سنحتل مكه والمدينه لكن انت
انت وين رايحين انتم اغبياء انتم الان
تستفزون مليار وثلاث مئه مليون مسلم كم
عددكم مليار و300 600 لكل صح مليار مليون
مسلم السنه انت لما تهدد الخليد او تهدد
السعوديه بهذا الشكل الملك ملك السعوديه
لو اراد بكلمه واحده
يستنفر مليار و300 مليون مسلم انتم وين
رايحين
هذا الامر هذا الامر يجب ان تعلمه الطائفه
ويجب ان يعلمه الايرانيين الامور ليست
هكذا العرب لن يسلموا سوريا الحصن سوريا
حصن الامين وسوريا الحصن الاخير للامه
العربيه والاسلاميه كيف ترد على الذين
يقولون بعض كل هذا الكلام ان غالبيه الجيش
السوري الذي يعتمد عليه النظام من السنه
من السنه ليس صحيحا اعلى الاطلاق الجيش
السوري يا استاذي الفاضل الشباب تركوا ليش
استعان حسن نصر الله نفسه قال لولا انت
دخلنا
لجانب النظام لسقط النظام ما ظل منه شباب
السنه تركوا الجيش والشباب ايضا الطائفه
الذين انت عليهم بشار الاسد قتلوا جميعا
انت شفت انت البنات بناتهم الان على
الحواجز لذلك استخدم هذه الاعداد الهائله
من من
الشيعيه هذا الكلام غير صحيح انهم لكن انا
اقول لك اخي العزيز هلا هذا كان في شويه
مجندين عم يقوموا ويجعلهم بالاول
حكى لي حكى امين سر الجيش الحر النقيب
عمار الواوي قال نحن سلمونا مهمات للقضاء
لسحق الثوره لسحق الثوره وسحق المظاهرات
بدايه كانت مظاهرات بدونه قال اعطينا
مهمات
ليستحق مظاهر الدومه السنه ومعنى ايضا
عسكريين السنه وخلفنا مين ضباط المخابرات
تصور خلفهم ضباط المخابرات لكن الان لا ظل
سنه ولا ظل نصيريه ايضا الان عم يستعين
طائفيه اكبر دليل انه هو يستعين طيب
كان معنا السيد عبد السيد عبد المسيح
الشامي ونتمنى ان يعود في اي ممكن يرجع
للاستاذ عبد المسيح يتفضل انا
لو تكرمت لو تكرمت ترجع الاستاذ عبد
المسيح الدور الك
سيد عبد المسيح
طيب
ناخذ عبر الهاتف السيد ثائر الناشف بينما
ياتي السيد عبد المسيح تفضل سيدي
بالنسبه لطائفيه نظام الاسد حقيقه من بدا
الطائفيه اليوم في سوريا قبل ان يكون نظام
الاسد قد اسرع انيابه هي ايران حنيفته
التي اسست للطائفيه في سوريا من خلال
التهييج الذي عملت عليه خلال الثوره
السوريه منذ اربع سنوات وحتى ما قبل ذلك
نظام الاسد اعتمد على الطائفيه السياسيه
منذ اكثر من اربعين عاما وايران عندما
بدات الثوره السوريه دفعت بنظام الاسد الى
التهيت الطائفي
واعتمدت ايران في ذلك على الفتاوى التي
اصدرها مراجع ومعممه ايران خلال السنوات
الثوره ومن ابرز هذه الفتاوى كانت
فتوى من ج
لال وادعى ان حسين خرج من كربلاء وذهب الى
سوريا ثم فتوى كاظم الحائري وهو من ابرز
معمنيكم ايضا اطلق الفتوته الشهيره التي
دعا خلالها الى تاسيس الجيش المليوني اي
مليون مقاتل شيعي يذهبون الى سوريا
واضافه لذلك هذا كان كله حافظ لمقاط نظام
الاسد حتى ينهجوا هذا النهج الطائفي وعلى
اساسه يمارسون اعمال القتل والاجرام
ساقول لكم شيئا مهما جدا وكان بودي ان
اعرضه لكم على شاشه قناه الجزيره وهي
وثيقه عثره عليها الثوار في حلب في منطقه
هنانو وهو كتاب يعني يستخدمه اتباع
الطائفه العلويه وهذا الكتاب يعتبر من قدس
الاقداس بالنسبه لهم يقولون في هذا الكتاب
سطرين فقط والبس وجهك الهيبه والقبول
واجعل عدوك تحت قدميك كالك
بش وهذا ما جرى حقيقه في دانياس وفي
الحوله وفي الترنشي ومعزاف والقدير وداريه
والى ما هنالك من مناطق كثيره
جات
هم يقتلون بالسكين ايضا ثم الفتوى ثم
الكلام الخطير الذي قاله الضابط العقيد
جهاد محله والذي انتشر في جميع باختصار
اشكرك جزيل الشكر يقولون ان اشكرك وصلت
عبد المسيح اريدك ان ترد على كل هذه
النقاط انه سرد لك تاريخه الطائفه خذ وقتك
وقل ما تشاء تفضل نستغل الوقت بليز اولا
بدي الفت نظر الناس على الديمقراطيه اللي
عم يوزعوا لنا اياها هذه الديمقراطيه اللي
عم يوعدونا فيها بس هذا الرجل قبل ما نفوت
على الاستوديو وقفت له انا عم احكي
هذا الرجل هذا الرجل لما فات على قبل ما
افوت على الاستوديو وقفت له لحتى يسلم قال
انا ما بسلم عليك طيب لمجرد اني انا صاحب
وجهه نظر مختلفه هذا الرجل عم يهدد انه هو
اذا انا مختلف عنه بيحكي اي كلمه ممكن
يعمل هو واخوه رؤساء ميشياد بسوريا ممكن
يتباعوا هذا طبيعي خلي العالم
المجرمون هكذا
نحن سمعنا كل الفتاوى اللي طلعت من
القرضاوي من العريفه واللي طلعت من
العرعور بسبي النساء الدرزيات امبارح لاجل
سيد سيد خالد
المسيح عبد المسيح خليني اسالك سؤال بس
مشانك انت خليني اسالك اخر مره اذا بده
يحكي اي كلمه هذا البني ادم
محجوب ولا بده يحكي انا طالع مباشره
وبعدين
يا اخي خلينا ناخذ الموضوع هذا الصراع
الطائفي في سوريا بس خليني اسالك انت قلت
لي شو اسمه
المسيحي على التابوت ولا شو قلت المسيحي
على على بيروت خليني اسالك بس خليني بس
اسالك سؤال صغير
هذا الشعار ظهر في درعا المسيحي على بيروت
والعلوي على التابوت هذا الشعار ظهر في
درعا كانت الشعارات في درعا كلها كلها
حريه حريه حريه اهل درعا فجاه سمعوا شخص
سمعوا شخص يقول هذا الشعار العلويه على
التابوت والمسيحيه على بيروت وما بعرف شو
القوا القبض على هذا الشخص في درعا القبض
عليه وتم التحقيق معه فطلع مساعد اول
بالمخابرات السوريه لا علاقه له لا باهل
درعا ولا من يحزنون طلع من النظام النظام
كان وراء الشعار عم تحكي عن سبيل السويداء
هل تعلم من الذي حرض الشخص من درعا اسمه
الخليلي طلع متعامل مع المخابرات السوريه
قالت له روح
متعامل مع المخابرات كويس كويس يعني هلا
بدي افهم مثلا جماعه السلفيين وجماعه
الاسلاميين اللي بمصر
النظام هو اللي صنعهم قال لي بليبيا
النظام هو اللي صنعهم اللي عملوا العمليات
باوروبا السلام عليكم
فكر يقوم على الذبح والقتل والاقصاء هذا
تاريخ من 1400 سنه ماله جديد هذا
المسيحيين يقتلون دائما الجلوس يقتلون
دائما العلويين يقتلون دائما يتكلم عن
الطائفيه هل تعلم ان هل تعلم ان
العلويه بس المناطقة خليه يكمل لا باس في
سوريا منذ
ظهر حافظ اسد وحتى الان المناطق الصيني من
يعيش برغد اكثر من المناطق الصينيه في
دمشق عبد المسيح
من المناطق الصينيه
انت تقول العلويه والمسيحيه والدروس وكذا
انا بدي اسالك هل تستطيع ان تقول لي كم
عدد الدروس والمسيحيين والعلويين
الموجودين في مخيمات اللجوء ولا علوي ولا
ولا درسي ماشي كل سنه عدد سكان حمص مليون
و 300 الف نسمه بكل اختصار دقيقه مليون
سنه تم تهجير وكل الاحياء العلويه
والمسيحيه في حمص بيسكروا الان وبشيشوا
هذا الكلام غير صحيح بس بدي اقول لك ليش
بدي اقول لك ليش لانه المناطق السنيه هي
اللي عم بتطلع على المجموعات الارهابيه هي
البيئه الحاضنه للمجموعات الارهابيه شئنا
ما بينها طبعا ممكن طبعا ولكن لما بتروح
مجموعات ارهابيه بتروح بتشتغل
صوتي اكثر منك وبشر
خالد
بدون شخصة عبد المسيح اكمل اكمل بالموضوع
نفسه هسا بيجي دورك وبتحكي ارجوك ارجوك
تفضل الازمه في سوريا والمعارضه في سوريا
من اول
الازمه من
اشعارات وخطاب طائفيه بالمطلق هم وقد قرر
هذا الامر من اول الجلسه حتى الان النظام
النصيري النظام الطائفي هذه لهجه لم
نسمعها يوما لا على التلفزيون السوري ولا
من الرئيس السوري ولا من اي شخصيه رسميه
في سوريا انا لست هنا كممثل عن المسيحيين
لا لا
يا اخي
كلامك في غايه الاهميه والله بس خليني
خلينا ناخذها شوي شوي وهدي اعصابك والله
هدي اعصابك بدي اسالك سؤال انا بدي اعطيك
مثال من منطقه الدروس عند بدات الثوره
جاء الامن السوري المخابرات العسكريه
ووفيق ناصر تحديدا بدا ياتي بالشباب
الدروس ويقول لهم يا دروس اهل درعا السنه
بدو يقتلوكن فروحوا قاتلوا على شو ثانيا
بدات عمليات الخطف من السويداء ومن درعا
كي يشبك اهل درعا والسويداء وفيق ناصر
بتعليمات من الرئيس
الان في حرب في بصره الشام يحرضون الدروس
كي يذهبوا ليقتتلوا مع درعا ودرعا هي بلد
انت بتعرف درعا والسويداء منطقه واحده سهل
حوران يعني بكره الدروس بكره دروس اذا
المي انقطعت عنهم من درعا بيسقيهم سيده
سياده الرئيس بشار الاسد
السويده ودرعه يد واحده
سؤال اذا من اللحظه الاولى بدا يدق
الاسفين بين الدروس واهل درعا بين
المسيحيين بين العلويين والسنه يروحوا
يقولوا هذول بدي اقتلوكم هذا نظام قومي
صرع راسنا بالنظام القومي وبعدين يا زلمه
يضرب الطوائف كلها ببعضها والله الفرنسيين
الاستعمار الفرنسي استحى على حاله في ادلب
هل يوجد جيش هل يوجد امل في ادلب من الذي
هدد الدروس في منطقه ادلب وقال لهم ان لم
تصبحوا مسلمون سنه وتحطم كل الاضرحه وكل
المقدسات عندكم سوف نذبحكم كال من الذي
قال ذلك
المسيحيين يعيشون بسلام
كيف ترد على هذا الكلام يا رجل الرجل
يتكلم منطق يقول لك من الذي يهدد الاقليات
ومن الذي يلعب على الوتر الطائف فانا بدي
اسالك سؤال بدي اسالك سؤال انتم انتم هلق
انت كل كلامك طائفي ليش تتهم الطرف الاخر
بالطائفي وكل مفرداتك طائفيه ليش يعني
يعني بتحكوا عن النظام
لا تسمعي اسمعي صار شي
حلب وادلب والسويداء ما في احسن منهم
واخواننا ورايحين وجايين اقسم بالله ما
ننبسط غير لما هيك نروحنا على السويداء
وناكل وننبسط وناكل عنب ونشوف السويدر
واقف وكذا
والمسيحيين كذلك لك اكبر اكبر اكبر
سوقين في في حماه سوق
المسيحيين في اسقالبيه وسوق المسيحيين
دكتور احمد
عبد العزيز ماذا قال قال قتلوا انقتل سته
في على ابواب محرده شمال شمالي حماه قال
جماعه انا جمعت المخابرات كلياته انه كان
علي مملوك وكان هشام باختيار لك قلت له
العمل يضربكم ضرب انتم قد النمل ولك شلون
هاي العصابات المسلحه بتقتل هذول بمحرده
لحمه بدكم تسووا بده يصير يعني بدها تصير
طائفيه بهالحاله عصابات مسلحه بتقتل
المحرده وبكره اهل محاربه بيقتلوا
هاي الدكتور احمد عبد العزيز موجود
والله يا دكتور الصراحه نحن اللي قتلناهن
قال عمي يخرب بيتكم ليش قتلتهم لانه
اسمعي يا اخي الدكتور احمد عبد العزيز
تسمح لي اتصل
احمد عبد العزيز كان محافظ حماه قالوا له
الدكتور بشار الاسد الرئيس بشار الاسد بده
يثبت للعالم انه هناك عصابات ارهابيه نحن
قتلناهم بمحرجه مشان عصاباتيه كلام ولاده
عبد المسيحي
احمد عبد العزيز اقاله قالوا لانه منع منع
اطلاق النار على اوكي عبد المسيح وليد جون
بلاط اليوم يقول تفضل ان السياسات التي
انتهجها وينتهجها نظام بشار الاسد قائمه
على تاليب المناطق والطوائف على بعضها
البعض
لاشعال نار الفتنه واطاله امد الصراع
ووجهوا لما يحدث الان في السويداء ودرعا
السويداء ودرعا
بني ادم في بني ادم طبيعي بالعالم ممكن
يسمع لواحد يعني عنده بكل ثانيه ما بدي
انا ما بحب احكي رجاء
بس دقيقه بس لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
العظيم
يعني يعتد براي مثلا
بشار الاسد يعتدي
النظر مين يعتاد
بس يعد المسيح
جاوبت عليها الان هناك كلام موثق واسال
اهل دمشق
نصف مدينه دمشق من داريا لست زينب لمنطقه
المطار السيده سكينه السيده زينب كل هذه
المناطق بيعت لايران باموال طائله واسال
اهل الشام الان الدمشقي القديمه لم تعد
دمشق اصبحت عباره عن مناطق شيعيه طيب
الشيعه ماذا يفعلون في الجامع الاموي ماذا
يفعل لماذا ترك بشار الاسد لماذا بشار
الاسد ترك الحبل على الغرب للشيعه ما بصير
التلطين الا بسوق الحميديه الا بالمجلس
المسجد
دقيقه دقيقه بدنا نفتح القدس نسقط كذا
وبروحوا بيقتلوا السنه في دمشق اذا صح هذا
الخطاب اذا صح هذا الكلام
كما حدث في عدل العماليه وغيرها وفي كل
مناطق سوريا هذا السلف يا سلام عليكم
طيب انت النظام السوري نظام قومي صح ولا
لا نظام قومي عروبي من 40 سنه وهو يرفع
وحده حريه اشترك فيها صح ولا لا قوي بس
خليني اكمل لك خذ وقتك اه طيب لماذا عندما
وجد نفسه في الزاويه لم يستعن الا
بمليشيات شيعيه
بس خليني اكمل خليني
هي التي
لماذا لم يستعن الا بالميليشيات الشيعيه
الطائفيه اللبنانيه والعراقيه والايرانيه
واليمانيه وكل هذه الطوائف هذا من جهه هل
سمعت بالامس ماذا يفعلون الان هناك يضعون
على مثلا منطقه الدروس يضعون الان هناك
فصيله يتحدثون عنه لبيك يا سلمان السلمان
الفارسي بتعرف انه عنده له مكانه خاصه عند
طب ليش
يعني انتم مسمح لكم تروحوا تجيبوا سلاح
العربي بس انت بشار الاسد عم بيقول
دوري دوري
لو كان عربي
بدون مقاطعه
يستعين طيب نحن بنعرف انه هذا النظام صدع
رؤوسنا بالقوميه والعروبه وحزب البعث
العربي الاشتراكي والمنطلقات النظريه وكذا
طيب يقول لك الرجل نحن نستعين عرب بس هو
يستعين بكل ما هو ضد العرب يستعين بايران
التي تريد ان تبتلع المنطقه العربيه كلها
اين القوميه العربيه اين القوميه
اسرائيل هم يستعينون بفرنسا الست انت الذي
قلت الان ان الفرنسيين هم الذي يدعمون
الثوره في سوريا او الى هم هم يستعينون
بامريكا هذه يستعين هم يستعملوه الاتراك
الذين احتلون 400 سنه
الدوله العثمانيه دوله
للرجل خليني اسالك خليني اسالك الرجل نعود
الى نقطه مهمه جدا نقطه مهمه
40 سنه بيقول نحن ضد اسرائيل انا اتحدث
تحدي نظامك اذا يرسل صاروخ واحد بدل ما
يرسله على حاله يرسلوا على اسرائيل انا
اتحدى نظامك هذا
النظام
وتبرع وتبرع تبرع بالجولان وباع الجولان
وحمى حدود اسرائيل هذا موضوعي خليني ارجع
للطائفيه
طيب لماذا تعتمدون فقط على بعض الحوادث
البسيطه انت تقول انه هذا النظام بدا
طائفيا اعطيني امثله خلي عبد المسيح يرد
عليها كيف استخدم الطائفيه اثناء الثوره
وحتى وصل الى هنا كي يستعين بمليشيات
شيعيه تحديدا احكي لي اعطيني امثله مشان
عبد المسيح
كيف استخدم بس هو عم بيقول انه انت الوقت
بعد دقيقتين اعطيني كان كان يمسك
المتظاهرين ويقتلهم ويعذبهم ويرسلهم لعند
اهلهم مشان ايش مو مشان يستثير هؤلاء
كطائفه مثلا سنيه ضد الطوائف الاخرى هلا
استعانته بكل مسيح الكل
صحيح
ماهر ماهر شرف الدين تفضل سيدي باختص ار
والله تحيه
السويداء ياتي ردا على الموقف شبه العام
في الجبل بالانتماء عن ارتفاع اولادهم الى
الخدمه الالزاميه عدد المتخلفين صار
بعشرات الهدف الجبل لذلك يريد النظام
توريق اهل الجبل في معركته الخاسره ليقول
لهم ان المعركه معركتهم في يوم يوزع
النظام على شبيحته لصاقات مكتوب عليها
لبيك يا سلمان وانا اقول الجبل لبيك يا
سلمان لا ترفع في الفتنه مع الاهل بل ترفع
في الحرب مع الغزاه والاعداء لبيك ان يجب
ان ترفع في وجه النظام الذي حاول هلال
الجبل بكل
الوسائلات كانت المخدرات توزع على مدارس
البنات في السويداء باشراف ضباط علويين من
اجل تفكيك بنيه الجبل المعروف بتماسكه حتى
بيوت الدعاء افتتحوها في السويداء من اجل
تفكيك هذه البنيه المتماسكه كان حافظ
الاسد يقول لرفاقه لن تستقر سوريا حتى
يستقر الجبلان يعني جبل العلويين قام
بتدمير جبل العرب سياسيا وعسكريا وثقافيا
بينما اعطى السلطه لجبل العلويين اللي
واقف فهد الشاعر ضربوه على ظهره حرفيا بعد
انتصارهم على سليم خرطوم الجبل هجروه بشكل
منهجي 600 الف مهجره فنزويلا ومئه الفرقه
ومئه الف بكندا نصف مليون بالخليج بينما
العلويون لا توجد لديهم اي هجره فعليه
لانهم استولوا على كل مقدرات الدوله
الارهابيين
لبيك يا سلمان
ايضا لبيك يا حوران
ضد هذا النظام القاتل والمجرم اشكرك جزيل
الشكر اشكرك جزيل الشكر باختصار باختصار
باختصار النظام السوري ليس طائفيا بل
عروبي الدرجه الاولى النظام السوري ليس
طائفي باختصار باختصار طيب النظام السوري
عروبي معي نصف نص دقيقه ليس عروبيا وقد
رهن
رهن سوريا الى الى الى ايران وانا اقول
بعد بني اميه يا دمشق ابعد العز ينكسر
الجناح فلا كنا ولا طابت حياه اذا دامت
لكم في الشام ساحوا مشاهدينا الكرام لم
يبقى لنا نشكر ضيفينا السيد عبد المسيح
الشامي والسيد خالد شبيب ننتقل
الى اللقاء